la tension monte sur les bords de la
manche entre le promoteur du futur parc
éolien elle marine et les pêcheurs
locaux
l'installation de plusieurs éoliennes ne
fait pas l'unanimité les pêcheurs
craignent pour leurs fonds marins dans
cette région la coquille saint-jacques
et rennes on a vu que comment elle
surtout la période de travaux aurait
abîmé ne te les les fonds marins les
fonds marins est notre spécialité ici
c'est la coquille saint jacques puis les
naissains de de la naissance jusqu'à
l'assiette quasiment avec et avec des
chargés de mission que nous avons un
comité et nous devrions pas tous à
partir en fumée d'une travail qui a été
fait depuis
depuis je suis là et par les personnes
qui étaient là avant moi voilà donc ce
qui pose problème aux pêcheurs ces
fameuses études censées avoir lieu le
mois prochain pour tenter d'apaiser les
tensions elle marine répond à coups de
communiqués
les études uxo sont des études
techniques maritimes habituelles qui
permettent de détecter d'éventuels
éléments métalliques et ou engins
explosifs
afin d'assurer la sécurité des personnes
amenées à travailler sur le chantier du
parc éolien en particulier dans les
corridors des futurs kablan souiller les
deux campagnes de tests en mer
concernant les opérations de forage dans
sillage des câbles s'inscrivent comme
des tests de pré travaux tels que
définis par la loi sur l'eau ces
campagnes sont considérés comme des
opérations de prêts chantier et sont
incluses dans les autorisations obtenues
par l marine mais voilà la réponse
apportée ne semble pas vraiment
satisfaire les pêcheurs pour eux ce parc
éolien ne se fera pas il n'en est pas
question
à l'intention de ceux qui ne viennent
pas on voit nos bateaux autour des
bateaux de bateaux en effet dégagé les
études en mer vont donc commencer dans
quelques jours la société elle marine va
déployer sa flotte attendu patiemment
celle des pêcheurs